c'était une grande première au vélodrome
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la première
manche coupe de france fait mieux
organisée par la fédération française de
cyclisme était programmé ce week-end
dans l'enceinte yvelinoise au total une
centaine de pistard élite juniors et
cadets à participer à l'événement le but
c'est de créer un circuit pour nos
meilleurs pistards donc on aux pistards
élite
ce sont des époques qui sont inscrites
au calendrier international
ça permet à tous les pisteurs donc de
marquer des points pour le ranking
international et de créer aussi un film
sur toute la saison et d'occuper et
d'animer le territoire et donc les
vélodromes parmi les têtes d'affiché on
retrouve et les pistards de l'équipe de
france kevin sireau et michael d'almeida
et françois pervis le britannique jason
kenny triple champion olympique a
également fait le déplacement pour les
cyclistes ce rendez-vous est avant tout
une étape dans leur préparation avant
les jeux olympiques de cet été première
compétition depuis les championnats du
monde à londres au mois de mars
donc ça permet de
faire un point de passage ce évalué par
rapport au premier cycle d'entraînement
qui va se terminer
testé également des vélos des braquets
donc voilà c'est une étape une étape
vers rio dans la construction des cycles
d'entraînement c'est de la préparation
et rendez vous important on peut pas se
permettre d'arriver toute la saison sur
des rendez vous importants
on a deux trois rendez-vous important
dans la saison et là c'était de la
préparation tout simplement m'est venue
à paris parce que c'est une compétition
européenne face à l'une des meilleures
équipes du monde c'est juste un rendez
vous à mi chemin entre les championnats
du monde et les jeux olympiques
on essaye de voir la prochaine étape de
la coupe de france fait nous est
programmé les 8 et 9 juillet hier la
dernière manche sera organisée courant
septembre à bourges